All right,
I'm very excited today.
We are at political and we have a packed
room.
I don't even have to make that up.
We actually have the standing room only
room at politico and I am here with
Michael Steele.
He is the former head of the Republican
party.
Can I say that?
Is that the official.
You were the head of the Republican
National Committee,
but republic.
Yeah,
head of the party.
The guy with the biggest target on this.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's also the former lieutenant governor
of Maryland.
And Are you still currently MSNBC?
I am
the generalists over to MSNBC.
So a one of a very small group of
conservative voices.
Did they let you guys over there?
Who Do we have to come in the back?
We get to come and get.
I get to come in and,
and folks are very nice.
It's really good.
I get water and uh,
uh,
every once in awhile I get to say hi to
people.
So it's good.
Yeah.
Wait,
who else are the Conservatives over
there?
I'm uh,
Joe Scarborough.
Um,
and uh,
me.
Yeah.
All right,
good.
Very good.
Okay.
So there's a ton I want to talk to you
about including Cable News,
so we'll save some for later.
So let's just start first because,
uh,
you are a Republican now according to my
notes they gave me here you are black,
is that correct today?
Yes.
Well,
you know,
I worked,
I've been working on the Tan and I've
gotten really good at it,
so yeah,
yeah.
All right,
so a black Republican,
that was the head of the party.
I know,
I imagine they exist.
Explain that to me.
It's called history.
Uh,
and,
and a lot of folks really don't
appreciate the very unique history
between Republican,
the Republican Party and the black
community.
It is our political home,
uh,
it is where we first emerged in this
country politically,
uh,
and certainly,
you know,
Lincoln and the abolitionist and,
and in fact the party was born out of a
fight between abolitionists and wigs,
uh,
over the issue of slavery.
And um,
the.
Thankfully the abolitionists one and the
Republican Party was essentially formed
Frederick Douglass,
a notable African American,
a slave and free.
A man was very much a part of helping to
build this party.
So we've got this very unique history
and as a young,
a young kid of 17,
uh,
looking at getting involved politically
for the first time,
I was like,
you know,
my mom who was a Roosevelt Democrat,
my,
my family,
very,
very much democrats.
And,
um,
my mother raised me to say,
hey,
you know,
go out there and discover and,
and decide for yourself.
Don't let our party affiliation of what
we're doing and fluency just because
we're Democrats.
And your onset a Democrat and your
grandmother's Democrat and your
grandfather,
Democrat,
and,
uh,
your cousins are Democrats.
No,
no pressure
out at night did the study.
And I,
I realized,
well,
this is our home.
This is the political home for the party
of Ronald Reagan was running for
president in [inaudible] 76.
At that time.
It was my first election to vote in.
And he sounded a lot like my mom in
terms of how my mother talked to me
about me.
You know,
as a young man,
I'm in this country,
uh,
and,
you know,
having opportunities,
taking advantages of opportunities so
connected,
it resonated.
And uh,
you know,
went and told mom,
hey,
you know,
I registered as a Republican and she
looked at me.
She said,
Lord,
what's the watch?
Do that.
That's all been good.
Yeah.
So that's a lot of the history,
but I think I'm going to guess that a
lot of the people here would say,
well,
this doesn't seem to be the party.
No,
but it's not.
Well,
and I hate playing identity politics.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't want to get into that because
that's,
that's a slippery slope on so many
levels for both parties who've,
who've really screwed up,
uh,
our politics with identity politics.
But,
and we can have that discussion,
but I think there is a legitimacy to
the,
to the point that we have,
I think failed over the last 50 years to
appreciate that history.
And I started with a history because to
me it is an important place to start
because it,
it,
you,
then you then follow that into,
uh,
the fight that would later come on,
civil rights and the Republican leaders
who themselves conservatives at that
time,
I'm like their,
their forefathers politically.
Uh,
the abolitionists were,
we're stewards of this ideal,
uh,
in the Senate in the house.
Um,
and Johnson,
Lyndon Johnson knew that and yet a
political decision was made for Kras
political gain.
And,
and that was to,
um,
that national politics,
the idea of controlling the presidency
or winning elections for Congress meant
more than other things.
Uh,
and uh,
we walked away,
we walked away from the black community,
uh,
and,
and I think we are still paying the
price for that.
Yeah.
So I think that's a good setup for the
first part here,
which,
what does being a Republican in Twenty
15 in America right now with our system
is so screwed up,
so wacky.
I feel like people don't even know what
that meant to you.
They've lost meaning because it's all
gotten con conflated into,
uh,
other labels.
And,
and so,
you know,
where this tea party as conservative or
is this,
and I just make the case that at the end
of the day,
uh,
there there's a thread of value or of
values or principles,
ideals that you ascribe to a,
whether it is,
um,
your view on the role of government in
the lives of the American people.
Um,
historically Republicans have not been
antigovernment they been for limited
government.
They think government is the legitimate
as a legitimate entity.
It has a legitimate purpose though
unlimited purpose.
Um,
whether that thread,
uh,
or idea centers around how you view the
culture,
in other words that,
you know,
morality and concerns for the unborn or
whatever the issues may be that that's a
part of that narrative.
So there,
there are broader,
they're broader strokes that have been
used,
uh,
or,
or sort of stripped down,
uh,
in a way that gets us into this crass
political discussion about,
I'm right,
you're wrong on an issue.
And that,
that's never,
that's never really the goal.
And I think the,
I kind of sum it up this way,
that I,
I look at the Party and I certainly saw
this as a county chairman and as
national chairman and a state chairman
that even in a state like Maryland,
I had western Maryland,
which was very conservative.
I had where I lived in Prince George's
in the beltway area,
which was very liberal.
You had southern Maryland,
which was conservative,
but trending purple,
you had,
you know,
so you had this,
these different dynamics,
and you have to kind of lead in that.
You've got to govern in that and you
realize that politics is really about
the art of the possible is not about the
art of the angry or scoring points or
gaining advantage.
It really is about how do I take all of
these disparate parts,
uh,
and different viewpoints and,
and figuring out how to effect a
positive change or policy of positive
change on a set of,
you know,
uh,
ideas and that that's gotten lost today
in his heart.
And you've seen this play out right now
in the GLP,
um,
this,
this internet icn struggle over
identity,
who we are,
what we believe and why we value that.
Yeah.
So to the,
to the point of,
of what the party actually stands for,
I'm always amazed by the fact that if
you take to like hot button issues that
are,
that are clearly democrat pocket issues,
gay rights and legalizing marijuana,
those are Democrat issues.
They,
they,
there for,
you know,
basically for legalizing weed basically
for gay rights.
But it seems to me a true Republican
that would want small government.
Well,
you wouldn't care what someone does in
their bedroom,
whether it's having sex with someone of
the same sex or uh,
whether smoking weed,
right?
Shouldn't that be a republican issue?
Well,
I,
I would argue that it probably wants was
that remember that the gop also has,
as a part of its roots,
a libertarian threat,
a very strong libertarian thread.
Um,
I've always been amused that those who,
who would argue about the limited role
of government on one issue but then
argue for the expansion of government on
another.
Yeah,
right.
So that,
that's so,
so,
so that
being authentically consistent for me is
very important.
It's like when people ask me about my
views on life and,
and I tell them,
I say,
well,
I'm prolife,
I'm very much pro life in a lot of has
to come from how I was raised.
It comes from my faith tradition and how
I've been taught and,
and come to believe in value life.
So when it comes to the death penalty,
I'm against it and I always get,
well,
how can you be against the death
penalty?
Well,
because I'm prolife,
you know,
so you've got to be consistent from
beginning to the end and that's not what
we see happening.
Can you think of a politician off the
top of your head that's consistent
actually,
that really is,
is governing off a real set of.
I can't take anybody.
I mean,
can you think anyone?
Can any of you think of anyone?
Anyone that's governing?
Oh No.
Because they're not allowed to.
They're not allowed to do it because
the,
the tensions inside both caucus of
Cockeye are,
um,
are,
are such the Latin coming back is,
is,
um,
is so,
so intense,
uh,
that.
Look,
I grew up in DC and so the nation's
capital has been in my backyard forever.
And so I remember Washington when it was
fun to be in Washington and you could
go.
When I was a kid,
I used to go sit on the capital steps,
11:00
when I was in high school with my
buddies,
we'd grab a liter of coke and
bag of chips.
The Soda,
the Soda.
I'm just seeing what is your guide?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
See,
I threw in liter of coke because I used
to say I used to grab some coke and a
bag of chips.
I'm like,
no,
soda.
Okay.
Just so I got.
We would sit there,
but we would sit on the steps or you
hang out with him,
Capitol police and so,
and you see members coming back and they
taught.
You go to restaurants in town and you
could see a table where,
you know,
a conservative or a Democrat or
Republican,
they weren't conservative liberal,
that was a republican and Democrat would
be off talking policy or just shooting
the breeze.
You don't see that now.
They don't,
they don't mix,
they don't talk,
they don't integrate.
They don't want to be a part of this.
They don't bring their families here.
They go back to the districts which they
should do.
But there's this disconnect and the
consequence of that is what we see now
there,
there is no reason for me to work with
you.
I remember when I was chairman and we
were doing a getting ready for the 2010
election.
Your course,
you're going out and you're meeting
candidates and you're sort of
interviewing them to see who you want to
line up and support and who you and not
so much.
And um,
I met this one candidate and we got into
a nice conversation,
you know,
solid rock,
rip conservative and he's coming.
He is fire and brimstone ready to come
to Washington.
And so we were talking and I said
something about what will,
you know when you get to DC,
you know,
because at that time the dems were still
in charge and said,
you know,
one of the real interesting challenges
is going to be working with,
with the leadership on the other side
and working with Democrats.
Oh,
I'm not doing that.
I said,
excuse me doing that.
why are you coming to Washington?
He said,
I'm coming into work with Democrats.
That's the attitude.
That's double down with
a 10.
That's it.
It's a lot of things.
It's not just tea party.
A lot of people put a lot of pressure on
tea party and,
and the tea party came into being on my
watch.
So I know very well what was the,
the essence of that in that time.
But what people don't recognize is that
movement such as it is,
that energy started way before 2009.
This goes back to 2004.
This goes back to 2002 big government
republicanism.
The spending on the war,
the Terry Shy vo case.
Remember the Terry Shive.
Okay.
When the republic is called the Senate,
back into session two to pass a bill to
prevent this family from the making
decision about this poor woman who was
in a coma.
Well again,
these are the people that want
government.
So on the one hand you say,
you know,
government should be out of the way,
but then the other you're going to call
Congress into session to pass
bill to tell someone what they can't do
in this instance.
That's,
that's the conundrum that the parties
put itself.
So who do you like out of this group?
You know,
I met you a couple of weeks ago that the
in the spin room at the gop debate and I
was able to ask Scott Walker a question
and I asked him about campaign finance
and I got to tell you sometimes you look
at someone and you go,
this guy is dumb.
I mean he,
he struck me as dumb.
He,
he just,
I could,
I could just see it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I could just look at him and see,
this is not a bright guy now.
You don't have to comment on that
specifically,
but not dumb.
He's won a lot of elections.
He wanted more than any of those guys.
But what do you think of the general,
the general crop?
I think the general crop overall is a
very strong group of individuals.
Um,
you look at the governors,
the governors that are in the race,
uh,
or were in the race.
Uh,
you look at the senators.
I'm Carly Fiorina,
very successful businesswoman.
Carly,
a Ben Carson,
very successful a neurosurgeon.
So it's a,
it's a diverse group.
It is the most diverse field we put up
ever.
I'm not just in terms of a woman and
African American,
all that,
but just in terms of background and
experience,
the depth of it.
I mean,
George Jeb Bush was a very successful,
did a good job as governor and in
Florida,
uh,
elected strongly two times a John
Casick.
Same thing in Ohio.
I went through hell in the first term.
Um,
and weather that storm.
What did you make a case answer to?
The to the gay marriage question in the
first year,
that was,
I thought it was a beautiful thing for
me that was an option inauthentically
Republican response.
That's the,
that and Jeb Bush,
when he talked about,
uh,
immigration again and authentically
Republican response because at the end
of the day what Jeff was saying and he
used the language that people could
understand.
He didn't come at it and policy and
political ease.
He used the word love,
which to me and to a whole lot of people
was a recognition of people behind the
policy that while you can sit back and
talk all the smack about,
you know,
we're going to build walls and we're
going to electrify the marina and do all
this crap.
At the end of the day,
there are people behind that and if you
don't appreciate that,
then you don't have a good policy.
It's not,
it's not a smart policy.
And I think that that was something my
takeaway in his discussion,
which I thought was a very humble and a
very personal way to talk about
immigration.
No one ever talked about it on either
side in those terms and,
and I thought he did well by that.
So in a way you kind of want to combine
these guys.
If you could combine a couple of the
issues.
Candida.
Yeah,
I mean,
well we're doing pretty good on the
Frankenstein part without the
combination.
I think.
No,
I think that they're in a real sense.
You're right.
I mean,
what I'm looking for at the end of the
day,
I like John Casick.
I like Jeb.
I mean I like a lot of these guys,
but what I'm looking for,
and I've said this from the very
beginning of the cycle,
I'm looking for someone who's prepared
to sacrifice their race for the
presidency.
That's what it's going to take.
In other words,
and Jeb got close.
He used the words when he said,
I'm willing to lose the primary to win
the general,
but really sit there and go,
you know what,
America,
this is it.
Let's just cut the crap.
You want too much and we can't deliver.
That's how the conversation starts
because it gets you into spending.
It gets you into programs that gets you
into the size of government,
that gets you into policy.
It gets you into everything that you
know.
We are our own worst enemies as
Americans because we.
What did we say folks?
We say cut spending last government.
Why want more in my paycheck?
And then in the next sentence,
why don't you put more money in that
program?
Why aren't you spending more on this?
Why aren't you giving to this cause over
here?
What do you want?
So the question for me is always boiled
down very simply,
and you know the model,
your,
you did a little economics in school
right now.
Well you know,
you know the whole idea of guns and
butter,
right?
And it was always you.
You can either have guns or you can have
butter.
Well I think there's a different model
where you can actually have both,
but the only way you get to have both is
by prioritizing.
Because in any given moment,
at any given time,
something is going to be the priority.
So that's what we focus on.
Let's address that.
So that means we're going to spend a
little bit less on guns today and more
on butter because we need to put people
back to work.
We need to make sure that a hospital
stay open.
We may need to make sure that,
oh gee,
that bridge is falling down.
We need to fix it.
Right?
That's the priority.
So we put a little bit more into that at
another time.
The priorities may shift.
Okay?
Whether it's something that happens
overseas,
isis gets stoop more than they already
are,
whatever you've got to deal with that,
then we maybe we spend a little bit
less.
We reprioritize and we don't do that.
The second thing is government gets out
and says,
look,
we're going to impose these restrictions
were going to make you do this and we're
gonna give you all this stuff.
All right,
fine.
I'm happy with that.
Great.
Right?
People like stuff.
Yeah,
but no one ever goes back to see or find
out how the stuff is working and whether
or not the program that you've designed,
no child left behind actually works for
teachers in the classroom or whether you
know the,
the institution that you've created,
our social safety net in all of its
various forms actually meets the needs
of the people who supposed to be
treated.
I thinking right now the va,
so again,
making government accountable for all of
that is important,
but also the role that we play in that
process is equally important because
what's happened now is our politicians,
you're telling them every different
thing and so if you come at this way,
you come at this way,
what happens?
They just stand still and they do
nothing and then they don't.
They're not governed by a basic set of
principles that you talked about
earlier.
So they are going every week,
so they're going every which way and
they're given everybody anything and
they're just sitting back on what asks
what you want and I'm done.
That's not what we want.
Ultimately,
we are actually looking for someone to
take the risk,
which is the bottom line point.
Are you prepared to take the risk to do
the job?
So when I was lieutenant governor,
my approach to being lieutenant
governor,
it was only have four years to do this
job because the other four aren't
guaranteed and they weren't because I
didn't win the election,
but I walked out having reformed a
minority business enterprise,
got charter school law passed in the
state,
um,
and worked on a number of initiatives
including the death penalty that the
governor asked me to work on.
Um,
and I felt that we had done the job that
people have sent us to do a.
Now the politics took over in that case.
And that's the risk,
you know,
the governor of Maryland,
that then my buddy Bob Ehrlich got fired
with a 62 percent job approval on
election day.
Um,
but you know,
people hate it.
Republicans in 2006 because of the war
and a lot of other things.
So,
but you do the job,
you can't think about the next election.
And right now our politicians are more
concerned about being primary or losing
an election and they don't do the job.
So that's really where I want to go with
this.
But do you want the 30 seconds to do
trump or should we just tell we get to
trump.
All right.
Thirty seconds go.
What do you make of this thing?
Trump is an enigma wrapped in a question
mark wrapped in.
I mean,
he's a lot in a wig.
The Wig.
Yeah,
he's,
he's all these things.
He's all these things that have upset
the status quo of American politics.
Everybody is.
Everybody wants to run a conventional
campaign except trump.
He's running an unconventional path
campaign.
Everybody else was running a
conventional campaign in an
unconventional time and they don't know
how to do.
We'll deal with it or what to do with
it.
And he is,
you know,
whether or not he gets the nomination.
All of that remains to be seen.
Folks.
We're a long way from the first vote.
Being cast
over a year away from the election does
not know,
but we're actually only three months
away from the first primary caucus votes
and that's where,
that's where the real rubber begins to
meet the road.
That's what voters actually have to go
into a caucus room like this or in a
voting booth and actually think about
who are they're going to give this next
charge,
two to be the president.
Um,
and I think that dynamic as you get
through this third debate on the fourth
debate in December and then into
January,
we'll begin to settle.
But trump has changed the way we do
this.
And I think that's good.
I appreciate it.
You know,
I talked to people all across the
country.
They don't like what he said about
Mexicans.
They don't like the way he talks about
women.
They don't like a lot about trump,
but you know,
every sentence that starts like that,
the next word is.
But I don't like what he said.
But yeah,
I don't appreciate that.
But,
and I keep telling folks in DC as long
as they're saying,
but then anything can happen.
Anything can happen.
So is that the interesting thing about,
about both parties right now,
because trump and Bernie to me are
hitting on the same thing,
which is that the system is broke.
I mean,
in the first debate,
trump basically said,
he said,
yeah,
I gave Hillary a lot of money and she
showed up at my wedding because that's
how politicians operate.
Right?
And Greg,
he's telling the truth on that side.
So you have the capitalist,
right?
The poster child for capitalism and the
poster child for socialism.
And those are the two that are getting
taken away.
So what?
So what do you make it?
Oh,
there's your ticket next year.
That's not set that sanders versus trump
2016.
I want to be at that part.
I'm going to have myself a gin and tonic
and popcorn.
Can you imagine that to be really like
in the debate if it was the two of them?
Because.
Because Bernie's people you unfiltered
trump's off his rocker.
I mean,
it will be something,
right?
No,
wait a minute.
So why is Bernie unfiltered and trump
office rock?
Because Bernie,
because he is a politician.
Why?
Why can't Bernie,
why can't trump be unfiltered to.
Well,
no,
trump is unfiltered,
but there's nothing beneath the filter.
That's it.
The tell that to all the people are
following them.
I've been trying to tell,
but they're not listening.
Making the more important point that
folks keep missing.
It's that I'm not.
Bring it.
Bring that attitude.
It's that attitude
that's pissing everybody off.
You think you know better than the
person who's following him
and that's,
that's just not,
that's just not right.
You've got to respect best where our
politics has gotten to.
We've stopped respecting the fact that I
can follow you because I actually like
what you're saying even though you think
he's full of shit.
Excuse me.
So,
um,
but,
but that's.
But that's.
But that's,
that's the American process.
So to do that,
you don't get to judge it.
I'm waiting.
If you don't judge it out loud because
then I may hit.
You should have.
Fair enough.
So I'm saying so I'm with you on that.
But to me,
trump,
this isn't a real candidacy that I just
don't think.
So.
Why do you say that?
We'll revisit this.
No,
no,
he is filed the paperwork.
He's disclosed his income.
He's got a campaign organization.
Trust me.
This brother's got a camp
paint organization in a number of states
that people don't even know.
He's got a campaign organization in.
He's doing the things.
Look,
you know what was a telling moment?
I don't know if.
How many of you caught it?
Remember when he wrote out his economic
plan?
What did you notice about what he did?
Anybody trump tower.
It's everything's that comm tower.
He had no cards.
Yes.
He was not read off the top of his head.
He read off of prepared text.
Trump is in this thing the right way.
Everything he's done up to now has
gotten your attention and now he's
rolling out a little policy on this.
A little policy I'm telling you.
Watch it because the attitude of the
folks in Washington about his campaign
is the thing that keeps him in the
camera.
Hey,
I get it.
I mean,
I do get.
I know you hate hearing that,
but it's true.
All right,
so.
Well I can.
I can hear something and being
yesterday.
Yeah,
look,
Huffington Post says they're not going
to write about him in the politics and,
right,
that gets,
that gets the base,
the base angle,
right?
So that was the longest 30 seconds I
know.
Trope,
right?
So let's just talk about the system of
politics because you're an insider and
an outsider.
So when you were the chairman of the
Republican Party,
how much of the job,
how much of your day to day was just
about money because that's what this is
really all about.
So let's be clear,
be clear.
Um,
the role of any party chairman,
Democrat,
Republican counties,
state national is two things.
They only have two things.
Raise money and win elections.
If you don't do that,
you're not doing your job.
So your day is made up of doing those
two things.
That is 80 percent of your day.
And,
and,
and on a good day where you will spend
anywhere from two to four hours dialing
for dollars,
which they're very few of us like doing
because it's just tough to raise.
I look,
I'm calling,
I'm asking you for $38,000.
Okay.
There's a lot of presumption in that
conversation.
Right.
All right.
And,
and because that's the maximum you can
give.
Did they give you a list?
I mean,
right when you get.
Oh,
we get their first day.
They're like,
here's the list you get,
get on the phone.
I got,
I was elected on a Friday and
that Monday I went up to New York and
did a town hall on healthcare and the
economy.
And uh,
that Tuesday I was at my desk officially
for the first time at the desk and I did
a three and a half hours with the calls
for,
for donors.
Then what I did was,
it was the idea was I needed to
introduce myself to these folks because
I'm the new kid on the block.
And um,
you know,
for some of them I was a little bit more
of a shock than they anticipated and uh,
and so it was more introduction,
but then,
yeah,
you kind of roll into.
And I actually had a donut cussed me out
and said,
you know,
I'm so sick of the party.
Every time I hear from you people is
when you call asking for money,
I'm not giving you another damn dime,
Dah,
da Da.
And I let him vent.
His brother went on for like 20 minutes
and I let him,
I let him talk.
And then I said,
well actually I wasn't calling to ask
for money.
I was just calling to introduce myself
and you wouldn't have said no to the
money.
He wasn't given any money.
So,
but,
but this was the point.
And this is another important lesson,
how I think you do this,
right?
So I listened to this man because here
is a longtime donor,
uh,
an activist in the party supporter who
is now ticked off at its leadership at
the political operations and wants no
part of it.
So I told him,
I said,
well look,
I'll tell you,
I'm putting together a business plan,
which is what I did.
I put together a business.
I'm a business guy.
So I've put together a business plan for
the Party and said we've got to raise
money and how are we going to spend it?
These are things that are priorities.
And I got that together,
uh,
over a period of time,
but I told him I was doing it.
I also told,
laid out to him what I wanted to do,
what my vision was,
and I told him,
look,
I don't want your money.
I said,
you wait and see if I do the job to your
satisfaction and if you feel like
giving,
give us,
give us a check.
Two weeks later you sent the check for
the maximum amount because.
Because,
and he told me in his note,
he said,
you listened to me,
you took the time to listen to me.
And so I thought about that.
And that is a big difference.
Listening to people goes so goes so far.
And so the money piece is a big part of
now.
I believe money is property.
I just generally do.
That's my philosophical view.
Like any,
anything else I own,
I should be free to do with it as I
wish.
I'm not.
Doesn't say there shouldn't be
limitations I suited in.
This is great.
Now you'll love this.
So the RNC had a lawsuit and that I took
over when I became chairman to,
to basically peel back on mccain fine
goal because Mccain Feingold took away
from the parties the ability to raise
the money.
Right.
And they created this system that we
have.
And of course there was a companion
lawsuit.
Guess what?
It was put more money in now.
No.
What was the companion lawsuit?
Anyone Supreme Court rejected my lawsuit
and picked up citizens united.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
so citizens united was the,
it was the case.
They decided to take over the one that
will be given the money,
allow donors to give untold sums as they
used to to the state parties,
to the national parties and the state
parties.
And they decided to go down this road
where you could set up these five slash
27,
which we're now living through is a
nightmare.
So I want to get to that in just a sec.
But I think everyone wants to know how
much does the money,
how much influence does it actually get
you?
So someone writes a $38,000
check or someone writes the shrimp.
Yeah,
I mean really what,
what,
what are you running?
Get?
Well with the part,
again,
separating the party from the candidate.
When you write a check to the R and C,
we going to take care of you.
All right?
Because that's what we do.
That's what we're supposed to do.
And what does that mean?
When you call up and want to talk to the
chairman?
You get to talk to the chairman.
Um,
when you,
now you don't bring issues to me because
we're political.
We're not policy.
So you can.
And some do.
I mean I've got buckets of ideas that
people say,
hey,
I think we should do this.
That's fine,
but that's a separate way to operate.
That's,
that's all political.
You know,
it,
it's,
it's what it is.
I,
you know,
we wine,
you dine you,
we take you out and we do big
fundraisers,
we do small fundraisers,
we're in your home,
all of that part of that.
And of course the access you get.
So when you have conviction,
guess what?
You're going to be taken care of because
you're a major donor to the party.
Yeah.
You're going to be invited to the suite.
You're going to get a chance to meet the
candidates fan.
Then you know the nominees,
family and all of that stuff.
That's what we do.
There's nothing wrong with that.
We've been doing that since the days of
Jefferson and Washington and all those
guys.
All right,
so that's not unusual.
What's changed now is this dynamic where
you have organizations that can be
created that extensively don't talk to
the candidate.
Right.
Which we know is complete bullshit,
right?
Of course.
Yeah.
You know,
you know everybody,
you know,
my,
my former chief of staff is now the head
of my Super Pac.
You don't think I'm talking to this guy
at some point.
All right?
So we'll,
we'll,
we'll go with the lie will go with the
fiction that it doesn't happen.
But what,
what it does do is,
and I'm,
I have to be honest with everyone.
I'm still evolving in a way on this
subject because of how I view money
generally.
Um,
but money in politics and I see what it
is doing is making it harder.
It,
it is becoming more of a distraction at
the end of the day,
whether you're a Rupert Murdoch or um,
you know,
some other big liberal or conservative
donor,
you get one vote,
you know,
you don't get,
38,000
votes because you wrote a check for
$30,000
so you get one vote,
but now you can put a lot of money to
put a lot of ads on Fox or CNN or MSNBC
that influence a lot of other people,
you know.
Okay.
So let's talk about that.
Do you,
are you really influenced by political
ads anyway?
Do you,
if you saw an ad tearing him down,
if he was a candidate for office and
saying that,
you know,
he hates puppies,
do you,
do you really,
do you really walk away from that
thinking he hates puppies.
I,
I really do.
My grandmother didn't work and she goes,
that's my point.
I mean,
I'm not saying it doesn't work,
but what,
what I'm saying?
And,
and Willie Horton,
by the way,
it was originally a Democrat and their
primary,
so we won't,
we won't have that whole,
that's a whole nother discussion.
I thought they'd like to put that on our
doorstep.
But let's,
let's go to the origins of the Willie
Horton ad.
Um,
but the,
but you're right,
it works.
So what does that say about us?
What does that say about you,
the consumer?
I mean,
I,
I just don't.
I guess my point is this is the ying and
the Yang.
So the political class takes advantage
of it as much as they can because they
know a negative ad is going to work no
matter how much you protest against it,
no matter how much you hate it,
you're going to sit there like this.
Wow.
Did you say,
did you see that?
And now today you're going to tweet
about it and you're gonna you're gonna
send it out.
So they know that they play to that.
Um,
and,
and that's part of that part of the
problem.
And the money does that.
What I tried to do as chairman and we
were moderately successful in the last
cycle in 2012,
but we set it up in my term in 20 2009
and 10 was I saw down the road that
money was going to be an issue,
particularly after the Supreme Court
rejected my case and took citizens
united.
So we wanted to design a system so that
you could actually participate without
necessarily having to have a lot of
money.
And we saw that with Newt Gingrich,
Rick Santorum,
and a number of candidates in the 2012
cycle who didn't have Mitt Romney's
bankroll.
But because of the way the system was
designed,
they had time to get their idea out
there and those ideas began to resonate
and that's when the money came to them
after the fact.
So there is this dynamic that that you
can play around with right now.
And as I will argue and agree with you,
it's distorted and there needs to be a
reassessment of how we use money in
politics.
And,
and right now I think it's,
it's used poorly because it's just way,
way too much of it.
So last question about,
about money.
Do you think both parties treated the
same?
I think there's a sense,
and this may be just there.
Yeah,
that you know,
that the Koch brothers run the
Republican Party.
There's more of these evil Mr Burns guys
that are running the party more than say
the Democrats.
I,
I'm a firm believer that it's equal.
How much money did Hollywood,
how much money did the unions,
how much money did individual wealthy
donors give Barack Obama into Rock
Obama?
Who as a US senator was up on the Senate
floor beating the hell out of
Republicans over campaign finance
reform,
talking all this smack about,
oh yeah,
you know,
take the public money until he got a big
ass check.
And then all of a sudden when it was,
when it came time to make that decision,
what did his campaign decided to do?
They didn't take public money in 2008
like Mccain did.
What did they do?
The suit,
they took all the Super Pac money.
They,
even though they weren't super pacs,
they took all that money out of
Hollywood.
They took all that money off of Wall
Street.
So don't talk to me about money in
republican politics and I'm not talking
about money and the political system
that's,
that's the reality,
because both sides love it.
Both sides suck at that teeth every
single day,
politically and maybe otherwise.
And that,
that is,
that's the reality that we're now having
to live with.
So,
you know,
talk about big money.
It's just now manifesting itself in a
different form because for 40 years with
the unions and Hollywood,
we're backing Democrats.
Republicans weren't,
I mean,
we didn't have,
we didn't have all these big players the
way we do now.
We didn't have the Koch brothers back
in,
in Ronald Reagan's Day or in the 19
seventies.
So the dynamic has changed a little bit.
Um,
was actually changed a lot.
But the thread,
the meme is the same and that is money
still plays a role in politics.
The question that we need to ask
ourselves again in,
in setting up our scales of priorities
is how do we prioritize,
prioritize its role,
because if you're going to go to a
public,
uh,
public financing system,
then you need to account for races that
are in markets like this market here in
la that is damned expensive versus a
market in Utah or a market in southwest
corner of South Carolina.
Is this an example of where Obama really
has dropped the ball?
Because even just yesterday he went to
Oregon where the shooting was a couple
days ago.
And do you guys know where he went?
Right after that?
He went to a fundraiser.
This is,
I mean,
think about that.
He was almost after every national
tragedy goes to a fundraising.
I don't know who scheduling this guy.
This is a second term president with
only a year left.
Who after this horrific tragedy,
I don't know who's raised in one,
who's raised the money for I guess for
the party,
right?
Hi.
Debbie says they're broke.
So I don't know.
Isn't that the most emblematic thing of
what's going on here?
That even a two term president on his
way out goes to a tragedy and then at
the end of the day,
his day was spent raising money and not
even for himself.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
I think that is something that really
sticks in the craw of a lot of people
and I can tell you,
is as many conservatives and
libertarians are as annoyed about that
as are liberals and progressives.
And so it is,
it is an American phenomenon that we
invest so much of our politics and
having money to do politics.
Um,
when you look at the way politics is
executed around the globe that come
anywhere near what we spend,
uh,
to,
to elect someone to office.
You think about how much money a
candidate running for.
I was with the candidate,
uh,
yesterday in New Hampshire.
I'm looking at a congressional race.
Ask them how much it's going to run,
how much it's gonna,
cost them in New Hampshire for
$2,000,000
in New Hampshire in New Hampshire for a
job that pays $170,000
a year.
When I ran for the US Senate in 2006,
my race was the most expensive race in
the state of Maryland up to that point,
uh,
for the,
for federal office.
And I raised $10,000,000
for the US Senate races today for 2000,
uh,
16.
Uh,
that race is now about a 15 to
$20,000,000
race.
Why?
And no one stops to ask the question to
answer the question,
why,
why is it that expensive?
Doesn't it?
They're right it.
And they need to continue to ask it
because you know,
it,
it is having a,
I think,
a very downward,
a depressive effect on our politics.
Um,
it,
it brings out the cynicism and all of us
because you just see a very small group
of people who are getting to play and
you're the one paying the taxes.
You're the one trying to make it from
paycheck to paycheck.
You're the one who's trying to deal with
all this crap that spews out of state
capitals and in federal government.
Um,
and you just feel that your access is
somehow limited and cut off and no
American should feel that way in my
view.
All right?
Enough,
enough about money,
money.
It's important.
It's important,
but,
and we can talk about it forever.
It's important.
It is important,
but it's,
it's one of those things I don't you
tell me how you get it out of the game.
How do you get out of the game at this
point?
Because under the current rules,
under the current rules,
because as long as you've got to
citizens united a out there where you,
you,
you and you can get together and decided
we were going to form a PAC and it may
not be for candidate a or candidate b.
You just want to form a PAC and you just
want to play and you're going to go to
the rest of the university.
You can now raise untold millions of
dollars and we don't need to know who
any one of you are.
You can stroke a check for $10,000,000
right now and your name will never show
up on any report in Washington.
Do we really want that system?
I believe very,
again,
going back to my and we can move on,
going back to my central argument,
money his property so I can do with my
property whatever I want,
right?
So if I want to write your campaign,
a $10,000,000
check,
all right,
I should be allowed to do it.
But here's the caveat.
Here's the catch.
The day I ride it,
the next morning,
the next hour,
the next it is fully disclosed period.
My name,
what I do,
the amount,
the nature of my business so that
everyone in the universe knows who's
giving to you,
and then that puts the onus on you,
the politician,
because if you want to be associated
with my money and all that comes with
it,
guess what?
You'll take it.
But if you don't,
guess what you want and that will have a
chilling effect because right now,
if you don't know that I'm doing
something that you know harms the
environment or otherwise is a negative,
for example,
no one in the universe will ever know it
except you.
When you write the check,
when you get it,
the check,
I'm pretty sure that politicians like
the plausible deniability,
of course they do.
So.
All right,
so moving away from money.
So I want to talk about foreign policy a
little bit because to me it should be a
republican.
This should be a goto republican issue
and we're in a freaking mess right now.
I mean I don't,
I don't think the American public really
realizes what public initiatives that
they're stronger,
you know,
the executive branch sets the foreign
policy.
So why is this of.
Sure.
But the idea that Republicans are
stronger and foreign policy and we have
such a meltdown,
right?
And we gave that up a while ago.
Clearly we gave that.
We gave that position up a while ago
when we started making some,
some,
some really boneheaded decisions about
how we engage boneheaded,
right?
So I mean it was just,
it's just
bad policy.
You don't,
you don't do nation building.
No,
no super power.
Since time began has been successful at
nation building.
It always,
it always collapses.
At some point it falls down around your
feet.
So where do you fall down on everything
that's going on in the Middle East?
We tried to nation build,
right?
We know we went to the wrong war for the
wrong reasons.
Is that fair to say?
But you also mentioned,
um,
and now because of that Iraq,
but especially Syria,
they're not functioning states in,
in any way that we define a state.
You look at it in two parts and the
first one,
we all know the history,
we all know how we got here.
All right?
So that's,
that's stipulated.
We all know how we got here and I think
generally everyone and including a
candidates now running for president on
the gop side,
some begrudgingly,
some less.
So admit that we've got here the wrong
way.
All right?
So we're in a bad space for the wrong
reasons.
Alright?
So now the tests of this time,
um,
is how do we go forward and how do we,
what do we learn from the mistake?
And then how do we not make it again,
but more importantly,
how do we position the United States
visa vi,
uh,
are our allies like Israel and Saudi
Arabia.
Uh,
who you represent a to two opposing
problems for,
for the U,
s,
m,
a,
and our enemies like Iran,
um,
which I really don't want to use that
term because that's a little strong,
you know,
that's a little strong because it's not,
I don't think it's there,
you know,
I don't think so
that kind of give them $150 million,
I don't think it's that
kind of relationship.
Um,
and,
and the strategic relationship which we
need to have with Russia and China who
are big players in the Middle East,
but so are the French,
the Brits.
So
where does that leave us as a,
as a nation?
Because it seems to me we go in,
we try something,
we always screw it up and now we leave
and we see what that does.
I mean it's a real mess there and we
created it.
So I feel like there's,
there's a guilt sort of associated with
the Americans.
We feel like we have to do something and
yet we know,
no matter what we do,
we somehow make it worse.
And now Russia is jumping in and,
and reassess.
And,
and I,
you know,
I,
we can argue the point,
but I think there are enough examples of
either hesitation by this
administration,
the Obama Administration,
a reticence,
uh,
or even just a lack of unawareness,
which they even alluded to just recently
about,
uh,
the maneuvers of Russia when you have
State Department officials off the
record saying,
we didn't see this coming due.
That's why you're there.
You're supposed to see this coming.
But,
or they call them jv called.
Let me tell you what I think this goes
back to.
This goes back to a,
believe it or not to the 19 seventies in
my view,
um,
when the church committee,
uh,
and the Carter administration sort of
came to this community,
a conclusion that our intelligence
organizations were somehow bad.
Now they,
you know,
CIA and all those guys.
Yeah,
they had their fingers in some crazy
pots and doing some crazy things.
We got that.
But I think what we,
what we are,
what we have seen over time,
whether it's Iran Contra,
whether it is a,
what we're seeing right now,
uh,
in,
in the Middle East,
um,
is a lack of intelligence on the ground,
a lack of ability to actually know what
the hell is going on.
And I don't just mean know who the bad
players are,
but know what,
nook and cranny they're in.
No know what their favorite cafe is,
know what their favorite coffee or Latte
is.
No,
know who their kids.
I mean just that level of detail that
was so much a part of the Cold War in
terms of how the US and Russia sort of
worked off of each other and knew what
was going on and they were so effective
at it that they created a effectively a
stalemate.
Yeah.
So who's fault is that?
That we don't have that?
Oh,
I think it's.
I think it's,
I think it's a combination of,
of political leadership that sort of
overreacted to bad things that,
that,
you know,
some of these institutions get into.
And,
and,
and do,
you know,
government is about overreaction.
It's about reaction.
It's not,
it's not a proactive entity,
they just don't,
you think they sit around and say,
so listen,
how do we actually solve a problem
before it starts?
That's just not,
that's not what they do.
So,
you know,
a new town happens,
a columbine happens,
um,
you know,
a,
a Freddie gray happens.
These things happen.
And then the government wants to come.
We're now we're going to come here and
we're going to fix this for you.
Don't worry,
we got this now actually now just step
out and I'll just let the people on the
ground deal with it.
So there's,
there's a little bit of that where they
overreact and they overreact in a way in
which they actually wind up making it
worse.
And in the process of overreacting,
they begin to penalize the players in a
way that prevents them from doing
anything constructive later on.
Because now we're going to cut your
funding for this.
We're going to bring you in for all
these here.
If they just did day to day,
week to week,
month to month oversight,
they have committees called oversight.
Do they meet?
Do they actually do oversight?
Whose oversight?
If you're doing this on an ongoing basis
and you're sort of,
you're supporting and guiding those,
those intelligence organizations.
A lot of the stuff that we've gotten
ourselves into over the last 15,
20 years,
some of that could have been avoided
because we would have had the
intelligence to know.
I mean,
look at,
look at it this way.
You know,
how many times have we seen in the
political process when you don't have to
count right on something or you,
you've misidentified something or you
missed brand,
that's okay.
There are no consequences from that.
Alright,
so the speaker didn't get that vote
because the whip didn't count it.
Right,
okay,
we got that.
But when you're out in the field,
when you're,
when you're in a situation like Bengazi
for example,
where you have cables from,
from the people in the field saying,
we need the support and the folks in
Washington want to have a meeting about
it.
That's where the things began to break
down,
and so there's this idea of having an
ongoing,
uh,
accountable oversight process in which
you are,
you are in the moment,
real time with what's going on,
I think begins to alleviate the pressure
on the executive branch and even the
Congress,
uh,
to put itself in a position where,
you know,
we're talking about sending in troops
and,
you know,
ratcheting up all this spending on,
on,
you know,
in reaction to something that someone
else has done.
Um,
I think that's a step.
Not always playing catch up.
I think we're playing catch up and it's
more complicated.
I know and there's a lot more to it,
but it's,
you know,
I tell you,
I've,
I've learned over the years in
Washington and certain watching some of
these guys,
it's always the simple stuff.
You know,
it,
it's this,
the things that you don't think are
important or the things that you just
kind of got,
well,
why are we,
why would we do that?
That's the thing you should do to avoid
a bigger problem later on.
One thing that's become like my main
thing,
you,
you were sitting on the panel on real
time with Bill Maher when Sam Harris who
was on with Ben Affleck,
I'm assuming most of you guys are
probably familiar with what happened,
but basically that was so much fun.
I mean you saw to me what became a
seminal moment and a split in the,
in the liberals between the progressives
and what I consider the true liberals,
which is where I fall,
but basically,
but basically a Sam Harris said a few
things about the difference between
Islam.
Harris was making a,
an intellectual argument based in
research based deal poles.
He was quoting tools and things like
that.
So that,
that's.
So that's the jump off point.
Um,
ben was making,
um,
a,
a progressive argument,
uh,
that again,
going back to the point I was making
before about people and how those pupils
and all those numbers actually
translated into people.
So when you start talking about people,
then you're talking about attitudes and
perceptions and all of that.
And it was a very interesting dynamic.
I thought.
So for the people that didn't see it,
basically Sam quoted a couple poles and
then immediately been athletic.
He screamed,
that's gross,
that's racist,
that's racist.
And then that changes the dynamic the
next day.
Every media outlet in the question was,
you know,
Ben Affleck Calls Bill Maher and Sam
Harris Racist.
Suddenly the onus was on them to prove
that they weren't racist.
So for you,
I assume when someone throws around,
you know,
racist,
you're a bigot,
I assume you don't take those things
lightly.
What was it like to be sitting there in
the midst of that?
Especially because.
Because you weren't even.
You guys weren't even supposed to be
involved in the conversation,
right?
That was,
that was,
that was the bill and Sam moment.
Yeah.
And I saw Ben Lean in and I went,
all hell,
here we go.
And then he started and I've learned
over these years that when two liberals
are going at it,
there's no need for the conservative to
opine or contribute in any way.
And just like,
Yo,
you guys work that out,
let me know.
But what is your takeaway from my
takeaway from it was,
I understand what I,
when I did speak,
what I was trying when I try to get on
the table was you're both right and
you're both reflecting exactly what's
going on in the broader population that
we,
we see these,
these numbers that reflect some,
some events or what's going on.
Um,
we look at extreme actions by an extreme
group of and we pejoratively projected
over everybody in that particular class
of people.
So you had this dynamic even though you
asked that Sam wasn't really doing the
right,
that the know and Sam was not doing that
and that sandwiches,
you know,
just looking at these are the numbers,
this is what this is reflecting,
this is what people are saying,
these are,
this is what the poll says.
Um,
but this is again,
a speaks to the dynamic of our politics.
Have we immediately go to the personal.
It became,
it became intensely personal.
When you label the charge and you throw
out the charge,
you're racist,
or you even infer that,
that that's an intensely personal
moment.
I'm in that conversation in which,
when it comes my way,
all bets are off because it's,
you're asking me now,
this is one on one a look.
I've been called an uncle Tom.
I've had oreo cookies thrown at me.
I've,
I've gone through this.
I know what this,
this ugliness in politics is about,
and even more broadly,
um,
and so I thought Sam did,
did very well,
uh,
to hold a,
to hold it and keep it from moving into
the intensely personal.
But Ben was intensely personal and
that's because he cared passionately.
And I think it's speaks to you can have
that passion,
but you need to know where the limits
are.
You need to know where the limits are in
the conversation and you need to know
how to conduct that passion in a way
that your point is,
it's not lost because it is still an I
thought he made a valid point.
And we're so because we don't want to
project this pejorative view about a
race of people,
about a class of people,
about any individual,
uh,
in a way.
And you certainly don't want to use the
test sticks.
And numbers to do that,
I take great exception to the fact that
whenever anyone starts talking about
poverty,
why do you immediately jumped to black?
Why is the image that pops in your head
when someone mentions poverty in this
country is the image of a black person
when there's.
When you,
when you talk about crime in this
country,
the criminal element,
you know,
crime is,
why do you jump to my community?
Yeah.
We saw recently a,
even on the welfare question,
um,
some members of Congress get into
trouble because they were inferring that
the folk,
you know,
we're gonna solve welfare by,
working in the black.
Do you know the majority of people in
welfare in this country are white?
Have you been to Appalachia?
Seriously,
because that,
those people are hurting
[inaudible].
They don't live in an urban inner city.
Why?
Why is their pain and their suffering
and their poverty less important for
focus and emphasis,
particularly when they're part of the
majority.
So that's sort of the danger.
That's the danger.
That's the danger when you start
pejorative sizing and start speaking
about a group of people in a in which
you clearly don't know what you're
talking about because you're not
reflecting what's really going on.
I live in one of the wealthiest black
county,
the wealthiest black county in the
country,
period.
So when you start talking about poverty,
that's a whole different conversation
when you come to where I live.
So you can't paint that.
You can't use that brush the same way
you use it when you're talking about the
folks somewhere.
So that's the problem people get into
when they start doing,
doing that,
that sort of,
you know,
stereotype conversation about white
folks,
black folks,
poor folks,
rich folks.
All right,
well they,
they gave me the rafting here.
So last thing I'm putting you on the
spot.
Why don't you jump back into politics
because I've sat here with you and
exactly the reverse of what I saw with
Scott Walker.
Really,
I mean,
I know you believe in what you're
saying.
I may not agree with you on everything,
but you get the system and I'll get back
in.
I,
you know,
I like where I am right now because I
get to get up every day and have a nice
cup of coffee and asked myself who
should I piss off today and I don't have
to have a meeting after I knew that.
So I,
you know,
I kinda liked the space.
I love the national dialogue.
I want to be a part of the national
dialogue as you are a.
and I think that that's,
that's a good space right now is as long
as I'm able to do it,
I appreciate MSNBC,
forgiving this conservative voice and
opportunity to kind of come out and say,
you know,
with my buddy Chris Matthews.
Okay,
Chris,
hold on just a second.
Can I,
can I talk now?
Can I get it?
So,
but I'm speeding as much as it appears
when he's yelling that I love hardball.
It's a great show.
It's a great political discussion and
that is a very smart guy and is very
smart,
intelligent conversation and we need a
lot more of that in our politics.
Well,
I hope you guys appreciate what I think
is.
Thank you.